las autoridades israelíes como dice el
informe se ha identificado desde mayo
del 2022 tras una sentencia del tribunal
supremo de Israel que decidió eliminar
las barreras legales al desplazamiento
forzoso de la población Palestina en
esta zona con todas las consecuencias
que hemos dicho cómo han evidenciado
ustedes las consecuencias de estas
decisiones para la salud física y
mentales de los habitantes palestinos
Bueno muy buenas tardes pues como bien
explicaba lo que hemos visto que desde
esa fecha que mencionaba esa presión
hacia la población residente de tasa se
ha incrementado de manera de manera
brutal tanto así que toda esta población
hoy en día estamos denunciando que está
bajo inminente riesgo de desplazamiento
forzoso y estamos alertando en el caso
de que este desplazamiento forzoso se
produzca este desplazamiento está
prohibido por el derecho internacional
humanitario y por lo tanto constituiría
un crimen de guerra estamos denunciando
básicamente ese impacto de todas estas
políticas en tanto la salud física como
mental de los residentes de esta región
de masaje
mire Cuál es el destino de si sigue este
patrón de intimidación que además no es
nuevo en Palestina qué va a pasar con
esta población en específico
Bueno yo creo que esa es la gran
pregunta no lo que estamos viendo que
este entorno coactivo
está teniendo este este altísimo impacto
en esta población que si sigue así
veremos seguramente experimentemos que
se vea abocada a marcharse de esa zona
donde donde ellos dicen que han recibido
durante durante décadas durante todas
sus vidas durante generaciones bien y en
el tema que los ocupo a ustedes
principalmente Quiero preguntarle por
los desafíos de acceso médico en la zona
que podrían constituir como ustedes
denuncian crímenes de guerra
Bueno lo que estamos lo que estamos
viendo Es que el acceso a la salud está
siendo muchas veces no solamente
dificultado sino a veces impedido y
sobre todos los casos diríamos que de de
casos de emergencia hemos ido hemos sido
testigos y la población así nos lo
cuenta en lo que mucha en que muchas de
las veces han sido impedido poder salir
de estos de estos lugares ellos han
establecido toda una serie de controles
que afectan a esa libre libertad de
movimiento y que por tanto tiene un
efecto muy muy importante sobre todo en
los casos de las emergencias hemos
charlado con nuestros colegas que llevan
el servicio de ambulancias y ellos nos
cuentan que en muchos casos no solamente
les han visto eh el el el el el el
acceso si les ha [__] sino que en
muchos casos se les ha impedido y a
veces incluso han sido atacado